hey what's up Samuel Leeds and in this
video I wanted to answer some questions
around tax and some of the basic
questions that people have which stops
people making money because I think in
do you want to set up a company how do I
do this don't need an accountant
do I need a company for my sourcing
business and then another company for
mine rent to rent business school and
then they don't start listen here's my
advice basically yes you should probably
have a company set up you don't need a
company to make money because you can
make money as a sole trader
so there's when I started out in
property for the first like eight years
of making money in property I didn't
have a company I bought houses as an
individual everything I did was as an
individual now as time went on I
realized that that wasn't the smartest
thing to do the tax change is section 24
in the property industry also if you're
buying and selling houses or you're
packaging and selling houses and you're
doing it as an individual and you don't
have a company then what happens is
you're not protected and someone if they
if someone Sue's you they're suing you
whereas if they're suing your company
Robert Kiyosaki he got sued absolutely
millions and because if they were suing
his company and they weren't suing him
personally he managed to save a lot of
money so so my advice to you would be
yeah for sure you need to know this
stuff but basically don't wait until you
have all the right structure the company
set up properly counts don't wait to
start making money until you have all
that setup that it's the other way
around what you want to do is you want
to just start making money until it's
like a problem until you're thinking
geez I'm making all this money and I'm
paying so much I'm not so much tax how
does this work and then you start
thinking about how you're gonna save the
money you can go online and you can set
up at on company towels you can set up a
company for 17 pounds and you can do it
in about 15-20 minutes anyone can do
that now an accountant could say oh yeah
but you might set it up wrong and you
might do it just do it wrong man just
start making money when you spend money
if you're spending money whether that be
on educational courses on my courses or
whether that be on clear cleaners or
will not be on refurbishing houses
you spend money just make sure that you
have a receipt because you'll be able to
claim it back so when you end up in a
few months time thinking man I made all
this money and now I've got to pay tax
you'll then be able to offset your
expenses against your profits which will
mean that you'll pay less tax so set up
a company you can do it yourself or pan
accountant it might cost you a couple
hundred quid start making money keep a
track of your expenditures and then when
you've made ten thousand pounds and
you're thinking wow I've made ten
thousand pounds then pay for an
accountant and sit down and start saying
about how can I save this money that
will generally be my client advice
most people say ready aim aim aim aim
and they never fire
whereas what I would advise you to do is
just go fire and then when you're moving
it's much easier to move direction when
you're moving when you're staying still
you'll never get anywhere so go make
some money go set up some deals and when
you making money and it's becoming a
problem because you're thinking this
isn't organized properly it's all over
the place Dan that's a great problem to
have you always have problems in your
life
most people's problem is that they're
just not making any money that's true
looking to pay the bills that's a bad
problem oh my gosh I'm making all this
man but I'll pay tax I'm not quite sure
how to do it that's a good problem to
just make money disclaimer I am NOT a
tax advisor or an expert when it comes
to accounts I'm just advising you as a
fellow property entrepreneur to property
entrepreneur so that's my little
disclaimer my agenda is for you to make
money because your success is my oxygen
peace out thanks so much for listening